all right everyone on the ward had taken
Ben to their hearts October 19 virus had
very nearly killed him but this 34 year
old walked out of two weeks in isolation
straight into his mum's arms his first
proper day at home in thorns and near
Bradford and it still hasn't really sunk
in I don't know just euphoria when he
come out and he was chatting to every
woman just to see him coming back out
walking after the state he was in when
little came in it was just wow
only his stepfather was allowed to stay
by his bed for the whole fortnight in
hospital I honestly expected to him not
to be moving and I said I probably fell
asleep for a few minutes and then woke
up and put the mask on so I didn't get
much sleep when I I said that was my
first reaction is is he dead and one of
the doctors said realistically is only
one in 10 chance of survival as the we
could combine it turned into the second
week I got a couple of phone calls and
they said there was a glimmer of
optimism and that's a glimmer of
optimism Diane adopted Ben when he was
just three months old
growing up wasn't easy he's partially
paralyzed but lives a busy life there's
no way can go because he loves hats and
wigs and music and dance he's gonna have
a funeral like Nelson Mandela saw ReWalk
die yeah I would tell him myself cause
it would be a carnival when Ben goes
every but he'll have to go in fancy
dress
ukulele is just one of his things he
always wears a wig when he plays what's
it like to have him back
you know just it's low in the families
is as much as is sometimes you think Oh
on the morning when you're going and he
smiles it's like sunshine it's like
don't matter what sort of gray day is
it's like sunshine
it's just sunshine and you've got that
back I brought that back in abundance
they are beyond grateful to the men and
women who saved been at the Bradford
Royal Infirmary this virus can be
defeated Tom Parmenter Sky News West
Yorkshire
[Applause]